♪ [music] ♪
[narrator] Give me a minute,
I'll show you how Cloud Firestore
can help build apps quickly
by simplifying data storage in the cloud.
Cloud Firestore is a serverless
NoSQL document database
that simplifies storing,
syncing, and querying data
for your mobile, web,
and IoT apps at global scale.
It simplifies app development
providing built-in security,
automatic scaling,
and multi-regional replication.
It works in near real-time,
allowing you to fetch changes
from your backend as they happen,
which means you can collaborate
with multiple users
and keep your data in sync
across multiple devices.
It offers robust client libraries
and built-in offline support,
so your app remains responsive,
regardless of network latency
or internet connectivity.
Cloud Firestore integrates
with both Google Cloud and Firebase.
Creating it as simple as selecting
the location for your database,
creating a collection,
and then adding documents to it,
leading to nested collections
and documents per your need.
Accessing data is easy.
You drill down into a collection,
and then a document
until you get the data you want.
Cloud Firestore allows you
to directly connect your app to the data,
run strong transactions
across hundreds of documents,
and run sophisticated queries
without worrying about performance.
It comes with a generous [feature],
and it's easy to estimate budget
since you pay per read and write.
For all these reasons, Cloud Firestore
is perfect for cloud-native apps,
including mobile, web,
multi-user gaming apps, IoT, and more.
So, next time you're thinking about
NoSQL document database for your apps,
take a minute and look at Firestore.
For more info, check out
cloud.google.com/firestore.